kovy d'âge un mot inventé par le
personnel du centre psychiatrique du
vinatier à bron dans la banlieue
lyonnaise
les quelques 900 soignants qui exercent
ici estime que leur direction profite du
coc vide 19 pour fermer des unités qui
ne rouvriront pas après l'épidémie
au total ce sont 100 lits répartis dans
quatre services qui seraient concernés
par ce plan est ce qu'on dénonce c'est
que la direction en pleine crise du
couronne un virus décide de fermer une
unité de 25 lits alors que l a déjà
fermé plus de 100 lits sur l'hôpital au
prétexte d'accueillir des patients
coronavirus or on en accueille quatre
patients coronariens sur l'hôpital sa
porte pas son nom mais c'est ça c'est il
c'est la destruction des délits de
psychiatrie publique sous prétexte de la
crise du court aux navires us il décide
de fermer les lits et de mettre en place
les leur projet qu'ils avaient en place
qu'ils avaient en tête avant de faire
avant la crise du court aux navires us
en plus de la suppression des lits et de
la fermeture des services
les soignants dénoncent un manque de
moyens
ceux qui prennent en charge les patients
atteints de colite 19 serait sommé d'
utiliser les masques avec parcimonie si
le confinement et toutes les mesures qui
sont mises en place par le gouvernement
sont là pour cacher qu'une seule chose
c'est leur incurie leur incapacité à
nouveau à faire tester la population les
gens malades et leur leur incapacité à
nous fournir des masques
puisque vous savez qu'ici au vinatier
les collègues qui travaillent dans les
unités qu'ovide on leur demande de faire
des économies sur les masques ffp2
d'accord
depuis le début de la crise la direction
a interrompu les réunions d'information
hebdomadaire qu'elle tenait avec les
syndicats pour les tenir informés du
plan de suppression des lits face à ce
mutisme
les soignants menacent de manifester
tous les jours jusqu'à ce que la
direction renonce à son plan